today our car tester Amano Schaeffer is
on beautiful Majorca but what is he
doing in the forest without a car he
says a bear has been sighted in the
vicinity and it's said to be a Kodiak
let's see if we can find it the Kodiak
is one of Alaska's largest bear species
Skoda has named its newest model after
it here it is four point seven meters
long the Kodiak is definitely large
bigger than the VW tiguan or the seeit
Atika the kodiak starting price is six
thousand euros higher than the attackers
but it's more than 30 centimetres longer
as in most newer SUVs the roofline
slopes down toward the rear the
sharply-defined LED tail lights embody
sportiness their standard equipment
all the engines for the Kodiak are
available with all-wheel drive depending
on the equipment line we're testing a
car fitted with a DSG automatic
transmission and the 2-liter 140
kilowatt diesel engine
Skoda rates the Kodiaks combined fuel
consumption at 5.7 liters per 100
kilometers that accelerates from zero to
100 in just under nine seconds its top
speed is 210 kilometers an hour
everything has its price so while the
cheapest kodiak goes for twenty five
thousand five hundred euros in germany
our test car with the top engine costs
roughly forty thousand euros the Kodiaks
interior does justice the Skoda
standards soft plastic elegant chrome
accents on the instruments and air vents
and plenty of piano black the Skoda
offers more length and more comfort
all physician manoa says the Kodiak has
comfortable seats and plenty of legroom
even compared with some other vehicles
at size a practical feature is a club
dish passengers in the backseat can fold
down a tray table that locks into
several positions so you can place a
tablet on it and watch a movie read
emails or play games unfortunately if
the driver puts a seat back down to a
comfortable position the trade table is
no longer level in the top position so
objects with a smooth bottom like this
water bottle can slide off the knife are
they culture the Kodiak is also
available as a seven-seater when the
second and third row of seats are folded
down the trunk holds 2,000 liters folded
up it holds a mere 270 to take a third
row seat the second row seat is folded
down and pushed forward and how much
space do you have in the last row
yeah Yamano says the back most seats are
for children or very short trips so
let's get out fast and take the car in
the road
[Music]
the Kodiak offers a choice of five
different engines two diesels and three
gasoline-powered a start/stop system and
brake energy recuperation are standard
and all of them scooter says the Kodiak
has off-road capabilities but a Manawa
says he wants to see for himself he
presses a button to shift to off-road
mode this prepares the suspension engine
management and brakes for rough terrain
affecting starts traction of speed
control in the off-road mode the hill
descent assist helps braking when
driving downhill in the rough 194
millimetres of ground clearance keep the
body safely above uneven ground
finger amanwe says the Kodiak does no
dishonor to the bear it's name for it
can roam the wilderness for many
kilometers far from paved roads of
course the Skoda still can't climb trees
swim or catch Sam
you